simplify three a times a to the fifth
times a squared so the exponent property
we can use here is if we have the same
base in this case it's a if we have it
raised to the X power and we're
multiplying it by a to the Y power then
this is just going to be equal to a to
the X plus y power and we'll think about
why that works in a second so let's just
apply it here and let's start with the a
to the fifth times a squared so if we
just apply this property over here this
will result in a to the 5 plus tooth
power so that's what those guys reduce
to or simplify to and then of course we
still have we still have the 3 a out
front now what I want to do is take a
little bit of a side and realize why
this worked let's think about what a to
the fifth times a squared means a to the
fifth a to the fifth literally means a
times a times a times a times a now a
squared literally means a times a a
times a and we're multiplying the two
times each other so we're multiplying
these five A's times these two A's now
what have we just done we're multiplying
a times itself five times and then
another two times five times and then
another two times we are multiplying a
times itself so let me make it clear
this over here is a to the fifth this
over here is a squared when you multiply
the two you're multiplying a by itself
you're multiplying a by itself seven
times five plus two so this is a to the
seventh power a to the five plus 2 power
so this simplifies to three a times a to
the seventh power a to the seventh power
now you might say how do I apply the
property over here what is the exponent
on the a and remember if I just have an
a over here this is equivalent to a to
the first power so I can rewrite 3a as
three times a to the first power and now
it maybe make makes it a little bit
clearer a to the first power and the
Association property of multiplication I
can do the multiplication of the A's
before I worry about the 3s so I can
multiply
by these two guys first so a to the
first times a to the seventh I just have
to add the exponents because I have the
same base and I'm taking the product
that's going to be a to the 8th power
and I still have this 3 out front so 3 a
times a to the fifth times a squared
simplifies to 3 a to the 8th power